check out this week's must-see movies  what is that I think that might be my  sister the blair witch is back haunting  theaters in this super scary  supernatural sequel oh yeah diary sort  of a sunny story in Bridget Jones baby  our favorite lonely heart is sporting a  baby bump and facing a big decision  which of you is the father I'm why do  you want to join the CIA or intent  suspense check out Oliver Stone's  Snowden a political thriller based on  true events surrounding the NSA  surveillance scandal you have a wish  people let's check out this week's fan  tissa patient so what's your weekend  ticket going to be let us know by  commenting see you next time on weekend  ticket